Try by day Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
That's what's scary.
Not Scary.
But to me it's just to see what happens with Jon Jones.
Yeah.
Cause now they suspended for a year.
Right.
And he's been out even longer.
And then before that,
so they're stripping and style and then Dana obviously,
you know,
he never sticks to what he says.
Sometimes he does,
but he goes,
I'll never be a main event again.
Like we can't bill book him as the main event because we can't trust them
anymore.
Wow.
I know.
Right.
So for John,
granted he's doing that,
that flow grappling event against the fuck out of here.
That flow grappling.
He could have been fighting for the UFC heavyweight title.
Oh No,
I'm just saying Lisa Jones some active like at least he's not Muhammad Ali.
Yeah,
I guess he's lost millions of dollars,
but at least he's doing something in combat sport or he's only suspended for a
year retroactively.
It's July.
It's up in July.
Yeah.
So he has to get but still got a while.
Cause we married before I did that huge laugh before.
You'll see 200 so when he comes back,
it's interesting to see what we get out of it.
I know.
And then he came back and he fought over in saint proof and you know,
look,
kind of tentative.
And then you saw Jimmy Manoir run through over in Saint [inaudible].
All these guys are getting better.
They're getting better,
they're rising up and you know,
rumble rumbles fight in DC for the title again.
That's going to be a real interesting fight.
Super interesting.
You remember rumble did land that huge shark you see in them?
Yeah.
Who knows?
In this fight,
he's got Neil Melanzane in his corner now.
He's had them for a few years now.
He's worked with a lot on his grappling.
He guaranteed was concentrated a lot more as wrestling.
There's a lot of videos of him running,
wrestling drills,
wrestling,
nonstop.
So he's preparing,
he's preparing to get up.
It's preparing for takedown defense,
fun fight,
man.
It's a toss up for me.
Toss up.
And then Jon Jones has all this laugh.
It comes back and he would say,
rumble for a reason.
Wins.
He's like,
what's up man?
Yeah.
Let's do it.
Well,
why do you think he's going to get a straight shot at the title?
I don't even think know if it would get a straight shot at the title and upon
coming back.
You don't.
He must like everyone wants to see the in it.
Maybe that's why fans demand.
It might be something going on by then.
By the time this time rolls around next year or July rolls around,
so he's gonna.
He's free in July.
Whether that means,
see,
I don't know how suspensions work,
but what I would had been explained to me is performance enhancing drug
suspensions don't even allow you to train with other fighters are on the roster.
Really?
Yes.
When your suspension is up,
then you can train with them.
I don't think you're even supposed to be sparring with them once they hand down
and suspension.
How that regulation,
do they know about that man,
look that up,
Jamie.
Think that's true.
Wrap this up soon.
Yeah.
I don't think that's true.
I hope it's not because it's crazy because you could help your teammates,
even if you're suspended,
you could still train and help your team and also sharpen your sword a little
bit.
Yeah.
It's like telling a guy who was an accountant.
You're suspended for a year.
He can't even touch a calculator when he's touching calculators.
Yeah.
He's going to touch on,
yeah,
go ahead.
Does that Tia Tia 83 Texas instrument?
Uh,
no.
They used to make them have them in school.
Remember those?
Now it's now your phones.
Rq later.
It's fine.
Three was like a fucking elongated game.
Yeah.
Like the calculator business man,
they took a hit.
There are no longer rent.
Who's buying calculus?
They're like blockbuster.
There's none of them left.
Man's over gain.
Jamie,
see anything.
The first article I clicked on was the one from last year,
so I don't think so.
But if the other thing to your point where you don't think he'll,
who says,
we'll get a title shot?
The lightweight,
uh,
the light heavyweight division is just El dinosaurs.
Besides the top few guys.
There are so old.
John's like,
I'm not fucking fight.
And show gun again.
I don't know how dare you buy it again.
But Jimmy man was a very dangerous fight for anybody right now.
He's a dangerous fight for John to the man was clearly not.
You are reaching Matt Matt on what lit up a OVN St Pru.
You see what happened when he fought gusts?
When he got cracked?
Yeah.
Do you see what happened when he fought rumble?
He got cracked.
He got dealt with up restaurant.
He hadn't dealt with.
Right.
It's part of the game.
Well Ovince saint [inaudible] just went fucking the full distance with Jon Jones
and a tough fight with a sleepy.
John Jones had a broken arm.
Yeah.
Got His arm broken.
That broke that arm by throwing kicks.
Right?
Yeah.
But my point is he went the distance and St Crute took them out pretty quick.
I think he's dying or I think,
and not saying per rather,
uh,
Jimmy man and what took them out pretty quick.
I think Madden was super dangerous,
very dangerous.
Striking first round for John has come back fight.
I think taking him down and beating him up on the ground.
Be John's best 100% he's a trip.
I'm thrown to the ground.
It's a metal.
Also John's different than anybody else in his length and is a bit tough to use
it.
It doesn't get hit really.
And his wrestling so fucking good.
Yeah.
He's just so scared.
Not scared to go to the ground with anybody,
but you look at light,
light,
heavyweight division is hurting the most out of anyone.
I think you could go down the Russia God dog and we need some new blood in this
bitch.
Yeah,
you might be right about the,
the main event in Brazil is Ryan Bader rivers.
Little Nog little dogs.
Like,
I'll fucking do it.
Y'All do what?
I've been fighting for 35 years,
you know,
when is a little night move?
Like a goddamn toward us,
but if you want to pay me,
I'll still do it.
He hasn't taken a same amount of punishment that his brother has,
but he's taken some big law knockouts.
Yeah.
Hope,
hope,
hope neighborhoods.
So could you knocked him out with a risk?
My God,
he like clothes line down.
Yeah.
And then the rumble one was just horrendous to suit.
I told you I was in the back of the locker room,
uh,
warming up Pat Cummings.
I'm a fucker warmed up,
but basically doing like arm stretches couldn't hit mitts.
He was so stiff.
I was like,
who's he fighting?
Like rumbles like,
ah,
he can't go out there.
I looked at his coach,
I'm like,
no,
I can't speak Spanish,
but no Bueno or Portuguese,
sorry.
Yeah,
the,
there's no commute.
Like he can't go out to man.
I wanted to grab his leg like a three year old,
not let them walk out the side of the octagon.
I think Brazil is such a huge hotbed for MMA right now.
It's so gigantic that they need Brazilian stars and you know,
for the main event in particular,
they're like,
just don't have a whole lot of options in the light heavyweight division.
So someone fucking wake up a little nug out of his slumber cause he's
recuperating a little log or big nog little nug cause they're,
they're waking up as slumber cause little big Nog is done right.
He's the little Nog they woke his ass up and he's like Alpha Phi Beta.
I mean,
yeah,
I mean he's probably asking for another fight,
but outside of him.
What other good light heavyweights from Brazil that are in the UFC that you
could like sell a main event?
Our clover.
Yeah,
but they already fought.
Right.
But glow over just got cracked too and he should probably take quite a while off
after that knock out.
That was a kind of knock out that you need to like not do nothing.
Lay Low.
Yeah,
he got flat line.
I mean,
so you've got that light heavy.
You got Shogun,
which I don't know what's going on.
Shoguns gotta be done.
If he's not done,
he's probably real close to being this what I'm saying like at light heavyweight
broke,
go through name in Brazil though.
Even more so like as far as like Brazilian fighters as far as fame.
Fabulous.
Machida she suspended and suspended for a long fucking time,
isn't he?
Doesn't Disney have a two year?
I'm not sure.
It's not good.
I don't know if they've decided or not,
but I felt like he got suspended for two years.
I mean,
you just look at the Brazilian fighters especially.
You're right.
Light heavyweight Machida was going 85 anyway.
You can float between two of,
I'm just thinking two or five guys he could line up with in Brazil.
Not a lot.
Not a whole lot.
I mean,
Beta already fought Leo.
You could sell that as a rematch cause remember the little knocked him out in La
a bad.
Yeah,
but he suspended all the,
you're right though.
All the,
especially,
there's not a lot of new blood in Brazil.
Okay.